jing jing corrió un total de 30 vueltas
con el club de atletismo y luego
jingjing corrió cuatro vueltas más
después de la escuela tres más durante
el almuerzo y dos más durante el
descanso el cif singing ha estado
corriendo muchísimo pero bueno lo que yo
quiero que hagamos en este vídeo es
encontrar cuántas vueltas ha corrido
jing jing y para hacer eso voy a
utilizar una recta numérica entonces
pues vamos a empezar dibujando una recta
numérica
y pues para empezar a numerar esta recta
numérica podemos fijarnos en donde
empieza a jing jing jing jing empezó
corriendo 30 vueltas con el club de
atletismo entonces pues podemos empezar
a enumerar desde 30 o bueno incluso
podemos empezar a enumerar desde 29 y
luego tenemos 30 31 32
33 34 35 36
37 38 39 y 40 bueno podemos llegar hasta
41 entonces jing jing empezó corriendo
30 vueltas con el club de atletismo así
es que en la recta numérica vamos a
empezar en el número 30 y luego jing
jing corrió cuatro vueltas más después
de la escuela entonces cómo corrió a
cuatro vueltas más aumentó el número de
vueltas tenemos que movernos hacia la
derecha porque estamos incrementando el
número de vueltas lo que ya aumentó
cuatro vueltas así es que nos tenemos
que mover cuatro espacios uno dos tres
cuatro
y caemos en el 34 entonces esas 4
vueltas después de la escuela nos
llevaron de 30 vueltas a 34 vueltas y
luego jing jing corre 3 más durante el
almuerzo aunque entonces incrementamos 3
nos movemos 1 2 3 espacios hacia la
derecha y pasamos de 34 vueltas a 37
vueltas por las tres vueltas más que
corrió durante el almuerzo y luego jing
jing corre otras dos vueltas durante el
descanso había corrido 37 pero con esas
otras dos vueltas 12 nos vamos hasta 39
entonces cuántas vueltas corrió en total
jinjin pues corrió 39 y corrió 39
vueltas y encontramos esta respuesta
utilizando la recta numérica
ahora vamos a hacer otro ejercicio que
seguramente te vas a encontrar en khan
academy
este ejercicio de aquí nos dice que un
ejército de hormigas rojas empezó con
100 hormigas y después el ejército
perdió 3 hormigas que se cayeron en un
hoyo otras 3 hormigas que fueron
devorados por un pájaro y una hormiga
que salió huyendo pues me imagino que
eso hacen los animales a veces y lo que
queremos hacer es encontrar cuál recta
numérica muestra cómo encontrar cuántas
hormigas quedan en el ejército lo que
tenemos aquí estas dos rectas numéricas
y queremos saber cuál de ellas nos va a
ayudar a encontrar cuántas hormigas se
quedaron en el ejército entonces vamos
paso por paso un ejército de hormigas
rojas empezó con 100 hormigas nos vamos
a las rectas numéricas y empezamos por
aquí con 100 hormigas en esta recta
numérica y en esta recta numérica
empezamos por aquí
aquí tenemos un 10 o sea que estaría
diciendo que empezamos con 10 hormigas
en lugar de 100 así es que podemos
descartar directamente esta recta
numérica y bueno pues seleccionar esta
pero vamos paso por paso hay que
verificar que esta recta numérica
realmente nos ayuda a encontrar cuántas
hormigas se quedaron en el ejército esta
recta no nos sirve porque empieza en 10
pero bueno en esta recta empezamos con
100 hormigas y después el ejército
perdió 3 hormigas que se cayeron en un
hoyo ahora como el ejército está
perdiendo hormigas nos vamos a ir hacia
abajo nunca nos vamos a ir hacia la
izquierda pues porque estamos perdiendo
hormigas entonces vamos a tener menos
hormigas de las que teníamos así es que
nos tenemos que ir hacia la izquierda
tres lugares
123 entonces estas son las tres hormigas
que se cayeron en un hoyo y tenemos tres
hormigas menos que antes y luego tres
hormigas fueron devoradas por un pájaro
y perdemos otras tres hormigas tenemos
tres hormigas - que fueron devorados por
un pájaro y entonces nos quedan 94
hormigas y luego tenemos una hormiga que
salió huyendo esta hormiga de aquí salió
huyendo y entonces nos quedan 93
hormigas así es que cuantas hormigas
rojas quedan en el ejército pues nos
quedan 93 hormigas
93 hormigas 93 hormigas y listo ya
terminamos